hey guys welcome back to brand-new view
were back on 400 and today we have tons
of info to talk about which that will
just happen to III about a new faction
coming a new game-mode and tons of other
stuff so as always like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreigner that
being balance changes future content new
heroes leaks and patch notes and more
and with that let's get started so first
up if you accidentally got a
notification that I was streaming a
couple hours ago I do apologize
accidentally fat-fingered the stream
button trying to close something so I do
apologize for that but starting today
and then next Monday for honor the
starter Edition will be free on you play
for every single person so if you do
want to play the PC version of for honor
with just a little bit of a difference
compared to the actual version since
this is the starter version go ahead and
play it for free right now and then next
the part that you actually care about in
this video
Ubisoft showed the rest of the teaser
and what we all hope to see from what
was happening in that trailer and it
showed a new faction called the waliyan
faction with four new heroes all with
new weapons armor and move sets before
characters that were displayed
throughout the trailer basically I'm
assuming are going to follow the
Vanguard heavy assassin and hybrid class
the first man you see with the weird
staff similar to Nobu she once again on
a weapon expert so I don't know what
these are actually called but he looks
like he's going to be the hybrid of the
group the man with the bow Steph could
possibly be the Vanguard the chick with
the dual blades will most likely be the
assassin of the faction and the man in
the air at the end with the one sword
could potentially be the heavy it's
basically a toss-up between that dude
and the guy with the bo staff but I have
no entire clue once again this is most
likely wrong and this is all just
speculation so let me know what you guys
think about this part and this is also
going to be part of a new event called
marching fire which releases on October
26th of 2018 sadly though we have lots
of time before that even comes out but
it still looks amazing regardless and
build up the hype meters in our body but
not only that they also showed a new
four view for game mode that they're
going to be coming out with that
everybody wanted the new siege game mode
called bridge yep we are finally going
to be getting a siege game mode type in
for honor and bridge is going to be your
standard siege the defense team protects
the castle or fort or whatever they
happen to be defending well the
attacking team tried to the raid and
tries to take it over in this trailer
they showed a new map within a fortress
with battering rams oil pots archers the
bow gun from that gauntlet map that
everybody hates and this mode looks
super developed and very big so this
might be one of the larger law
her game modes in the game as as
obviously Dominion is like a 10 to 15
minute game at most where this could
last a little bit longer maybe you're on
the same time as that depending on what
Lobby you happen to be put in but we
also got to see some of the combat of
the new characters fighting the old cast
and absolutely kicking their ass the guy
we showed at the end that was up in the
air is first up and it looks like he's
very agile I with the ability to perform
moves with his sword facing towards and
away from him next is the chick with the
dual blades who swiftly executed a
peacekeeper very swiftly on top of her
how fitting because she kind of reminds
me of a peacekeepers over playstyle
might be very similar since they also
have two weapons
the third is gonna be my new main the bo
staff with her I've been preaching about
a bo staff guy for ages who looks like
he's going to be using the ends of both
of his bo staffs to beat enemies and
also use it as a leverage to get a
higher Vantage on the opponent and stuff
like that so this looks absolutely
amazing and then lastly we ended with
the old men in the beginning who also
seems to have a similar play style with
the bo staff character we talked about
but a little bit more Swift kicks and
not as agile probably due to his old age
compared to the bo staff user new armor
is also going to be coming here as well
by the looks of this warden with the new
plated armor which if it looks
absolutely badass I mean come on
just look at that armor can't wait to
finally get some new armor in this game
it's been way too damn long since we've
gotten it and just we've just been
getting a bunch of random pieces from
older levels just rework so that we get
better stats finally can't wait to get
some new armor in this game and
according to the developers the next dev
stream on Thursday is going to be
covering lots more info so stay tuned
for that in the next couple days I'm
assuming it's going to be on this topic
hopefully if they're not click baiting
us and they're just going to talk about
some dumb [ __ ] but I'm assuming it's
going to be more in-depth look at what
these characters are and all that good
stuff so like I said stay tuned to the
channel so I can cover that all for you
guys this upcoming Thursday if you guys
liked the video and you are hyped
definitely leave a like on this video
and subscribe for if you're new I cover
like I said the informational side of
for honor that being the balance changes
future content new hero leaks patch
notes and more just like what I did
today and tons more coming to the
channel of course this upcoming Thursday
my two most recent videos will be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out with that guys hope you have a great
yesterday thank you for watching the
video tell me in the comments would you
guys like the most about this trailer
and with that peace out guys enjoy the
rest of your day